Jericka Thank You unsigned NFL
quarterback Colin Kaepernick one of the
original faces of the NFL sideline
protests will play a leading role in
Nikes Nikes 30th anniversary just do it
campaign the former San Francisco 49er
tweeted this ad yesterday saying believe
in something even if it means
sacrificing everything thanks says the
campaign celebrates some of the most
inspirational athletes today who have
chased dreams no matter the obstacle or
outcome the campaign also features NFL
wide receiver Odell Beckham jr. and
tennis star Serena Williams Williams
said she was especially proud to be part
of the family Colin Kaepernick began the
player protests against social injustice
in 2016 by kneeling during the national
anthem he is suing team owners accusing
them of colluding to keep him out of the
league while Kaepernick is receiving
support on social media some critics
have reacted by destroying Nike gear
like sneakers and socks and so others
have said that they're gonna go buy more
Nike items because they want to support
the decision and a lot of people are
calling this a bold move by Nike they've
been had a contract with Kaepernick
since 2011 I didn't know that they
continued to pay him all this time and
they've even just extended his contract
so it shows Nikes very loyal memory they
stuck with Tiger Woods back in the day
when he had his issues yeah it's very
they're sending I think a very clear
message about how they feel about this I
agree I agree with that just as this
case is going forward against the NFL
yes and NFL season begins on Thursday
what's going on like going on